we want law-abiding citizens to be able  to own their own firearms to protect  their own life liberty pursuit of  happiness as well as children in the  home it is so this is the argument from  the left look let me make sure that you  guys understand this because we've done  changed my minds on this and i don't  want you to get tripped up they say oh  are you pro-life and you know what's  coming is then are you pro insert any  free government program here if you're  pro-life you should support more school  funding if you're pro-life you should  support two years maternity slash  paternity slash bleeding persons leaf if  you're pro-life and they go through a  list  no no pro-life means the right to life  it doesn't mean the right to force  someone else at gunpoint to pay for  services that you want let's be really  clear about that it's a weak argument